remember last night we told you about
Joe Biden's problems with woke
immigration activists well on tonight's
episode of are they left enough we turn
to Pete Buddha judge he's under fire for
saying this in 2011 kids need to see
evidence that education is gonna work
for them right there are a lot of kids
especially the lower income minority
neighborhoods who literally just haven't
seen it work there isn't somebody they
know personally and I think testifies to
the value of education
well that newly resurfaced video he
looks 12 in it has the radical left
riled up activists w khmho bell tweeting
that mayor Pete is going for less than
zero percent of african-american support
Hillary AK Candace Owens founded the
Ville exit movement and author of the
forthcoming book blackout along with
Scott Bolden attorney and former chair
of the DC Democrat Party Candace he's
already out apologizing for that comment
so how can anyone survive the Democrat
leftist buzz saw well it's really simple
all you have to do is not tell the truth
you see Buddha has made the mistake of
telling the truths a lot of minority
people are suffering in inner cities a
literacy rate is an actual epidemic that
is happening in America right now
unfortunately when you speak the truth
you get out you get your entire career
assassinated by the left because they
don't know how to stand up and tell the
truth what you needed this images you
needed images of positive people were
education pays off he didn't say talk
about the illiteracy you know I know he
didn't know what I'm saying is I is he's
saying that the education does not work
for minority people that's a fact
because they don't have positive images
an education paying off and that's
really ignorant if you ask me really
educated people and if he thinks that
poor black children in our community in
challenged communities are there because
they don't have positive images well I'm
in those communities and I'm a very
positive image they suffer from
underfunding of schools
systemic racism I go education ACOG oh I
just spent quite we get when we arrived
there in late September this teacher
strike was just authorized and it went
on for a number a couple weeks forever
they I believe are the
is paid teachers in the country if not
in the top two or three they were
already previously the highest paid well
you talked to the you know the faith
community leaders in Southside Englewood
all they talk about is education kids
are dangerous to go to school they got a
lot of drug dealers on the corners got a
lot of gangbangers on the corner and
those so I think that's what Buddha
judge was probably getting at those are
believed did my brother's keeper
initiative right he said men need to
stand up in the inner city and be a
strong male role models he said that so
isn't that kind of like voter judge it's
the truth
I don't understand why you don't like
America getting better it's the problem
Buddha judge is he speaks with authority
he knows not he talks about these strong
blackmail images or images the powerful
as if that's the problem and it's all
the things that you just named in the
community that compete with those type
of mentors we got I think there are
enough strong male role models and
father figures in underprivileged areas
to absolutely you don't have to live in
the privileged area to when the single
mother is 74% in these communities
single motherhood reign and you are
pretending there are strong male figures
you have now joined the side of a
delusional and this is why the black
community never got better because you
want and say we have a problem the
education we need fathers back in the
home this is why Republicans and
conservatives are winning because we
simply tell the truth black people have
all come from broken families the
narrative we have Scott Boldin's and we
have Barack Obama's but they're not in
people's lives every day I think that's
the point he was trying to get at and we
all need that I mean all kids need it
everyone who bombers got boil you don't
know number of them that are in the
community and what about social
organizations who do tons of mentorship
in those commands it's more than that
it's not
all the issues nice driving simple crazy
talk over each other alright we have to
play Buddha judges comments today which
was pretty significant walk back what I
said in that comment before I became
mayor does not reflect the totality of
my understanding then and certainly now
about the obstacles that students of
color face in our system today real
quick don't interrupt each other Candace
what are you saying well he's blocking
back because he's weak and this is why
people prefer Trump because Trump would
not walk back on telling the truth when
you break down the family Union which
has been done strategically by the
Democrats since the 1960s the children
run to the street when the children run
to the street their idols become
cultural icons people don't know who you
are in black America but I bet you they
all know who jay-z and Ti and all these
rappers are this is we have a cultural
problem in black America and we need
leaders that have the spine to be able
to admit that if we're ever going to get
that guy we have so many strong black
men and black women whether they know me
or Barack Obama or not whether they are
just hardworking people that these kids
too can look up to people need to care
about these kids invest in these kids
and you don't have to be a cultural icon
to do that if you think that's the only
problem is because you have broken
families there are a lot of other
challenges and anybody that thinks that
is delusional alright guys thank you so
much Candace and Scott on that note
Happy Thanksgiving